CBS News is launching a new series and
we're calling it financial fallout this
is all part of our commitment to show
you the impact the virus is having on
the economy from jobs to Wall Street's
to small businesses everybody is just
trying to hang on and stay afloat so
it's been a week since the Small
Business Administration opened its
paycheck protection program they're
calling it to applicants the government
is offering three hundred and forty nine
billion dollars in forgivable loans to
small businesses as senior national
correspondent Jim Axelrod reports for
some desperate companies that promise
relief is not coming fast enough
9:07 death lemonhope SATs Owens
Butterfield market a New York City
grocery and catering company his family
has run for forty five years we had
2,000 customers a day walking in and
right now we're you know averaging just
a couple hundred Oh SATs is staring down
a cold reality facing small business
owners across the country anything else
good revenue sinking how long can he
keep afloat a few more weeks
realistically we're still an essential
business but our funds are running low
the downturn couldn't have come at a
worse time
Oh SATs was in the midst of the biggest
expansion in the company's history this
is caught in the middle
a sister market around the corner that
would have created 70 new jobs it's
difficult to think that you know that
this might not happen but I'm I'm
hopeful that that it will last Friday
the federal government tried to twist
open the spigot on the Paycheck
protection program money to help small
businesses cover payroll for eight weeks
that the businesses retain their
employees the loan is forgiven the cash
comes from the federal treasury but
Americans have to apply through their
banks they heard that the funds will be
released in
the last half of April realistically
that's a two to three weeks away so
we'll see the system is not prepared and
capable of processing all these millions
of loans that's the worry
not only did alan duels accounting firm
guide Butterfield and more than a dozen
of his other clients as they applied for
stimulus loans he applied for one
himself not a single one has seen a
penny yet the SBA has never gone through
anything at this before and I have the
sense that they were overwhelmed it's
not just the government it's the banks
too we obtained this message from Wells
Fargo explaining delays due to high
demand and warning there will be limited
funds that could run out chase bank told
dual his loan is coming in a couple of
days but he's not counting on that I'm
trying to be realistic about it
and I'm telling my clients the same
thing never in American history has so
much of the economy simply vanished
so quickly a 10-block walk in new york
offered a glimpse of the evidence
storefront after storefront small
businesses plastered with makeshift
one-page distressed notes while
communicating the same message we're
closed
the plan is being changed every day and
it seems like the individuals that are
making the changes don't seem to know
themselves what direction to go for so
killing his own simply wholesome a
restaurant and market in Los Angeles
since 1984 Monday morning I go into my
branch to talk to my my banker he didn't
know what was going on he was in shock
your own banker didn't know how to
access the money from the SBA he wasn't
even informed so he couldn't even form
us to apply because he didn't know is it
frustrating for you when you're hearing
no no the SBA is gonna get involved and
they are going to provide a safety net
but when that's the question that's the
million-dollar question
on Tuesday President Trump abruptly
rousted the watchdog charged with
spotting corruption in the more than two
trillion dollars that's just starting to
flood the economy it's going to be a
literal playground for fraud Neil
Barofsky served as the
special inspector general during the
2008 financial crisis if there's money
and this firepower gets wasted you're
missing an opportunity to get it right
we just cannot afford right now to get
it wrong
now the SBA did respond to any of our
questions including one is basic is how
much money has actually arrived in the
hands of a small business owner so far
and here might be a reason why last year
all of last year
the SBA received about 60,000 loan
applications just last week they
received nearly 500,000 Anthony well
what a staggering number and so many
businesses feeling really desperate
right now thanks